it's one of the things that I still use
to this date it's one of the most
important lessons I ever learned in my
life and I think it's a topic that's
just completely ignored in the education
system right now
what's up believe nation at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in this world so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna look
at the seven things that they should
have taught you in school but didn't
hope you enjoy okay let's kick it off
with way number one how to learn verses
memorize this is the biggest complaint
that people have with the education
system is that they teach people how to
memorize things and don't focus enough
time on how to learn unless I'm not
going to knock the the education system
completely I think a lot of learning is
actually done but there is a lot of
memorizing that people have to do to
pass a test and that is not the equal of
you actually learning something
understanding and memorizing who the
18th president is is not going to help
you get a job somewhere what companies
want to see is your ability to be
creative your ability to think your
ability to learn you ability to process
things quickly and a lot of that is
taught I think in the education system
but a lot of it isn't and I think that's
a piece that frustrates people the most
if I want to know who the 18th president
is I can look it up if I want to know
you know what the capital of whatever
state or province is I can look it up a
lot of the facts a lot of the statistics
you can look it up now your ability to
get a job is no longer determined by how
much you can memorize and instead how
much you can think and I think this is
the single biggest thing that's the
school system is missing and needs to
improve so that's the easiest one but I
got six more I think are really helpful
number two is understand what success
looks like for you
[Music]
I think typically we've had this culture
where success looks like a certain thing
right success looks like you go to
school then you go to high school you go
to university or college and you go and
you get a job when you say with one
company for the rest of your life and
that has been the traditional model that
you know our parents might have gone
through and now success looks very
different
success for people has so many different
options and I don't think the school
system is a great job of exposing the
different options and at least opening
people's eyes to what success could look
like for them it's no longer you have to
go to school and you have to go get a
job at a company it's how can my
education help me determine what success
looks like for me and give me the best
experience possible to help me achieve
that success and so I would love to see
whether this is through the guidance
counselor program or there's a class on
it in the school system where you were
actually helping the students define
what a success look like for you and
then mapping out a course curriculum and
extracurricular activities and tapping
into the alumni network and every
resource of school has to help each
student build towards their path and I
think you can give the students a lot of
onus and responsibility it doesn't only
have to be on the teachers to do this
and you think was a lot of time a lot of
expense to figure that out if that's a
class if building your life is a class
and helping you acquire the skills to
get there I think ultimately that's the
most important class that you can have
in the school system and allowing people
to build that plan for themselves so I
think a lot of the education system just
drains people to get a job and I think
people don't want to go that path
anymore and that's leading down a really
frustrating path for a lot of students
[Music]
the number three thing they shoulda
taught you in school but they didn't is
self-confidence I think the greatest
gift that you can give students is
self-confidence just to believe in
themselves more and yes I'm biased
because I'm the believed guy but the
ability to help the students figure out
how they can believe in themselves more
in their projects in themselves in the
curricular activities that they're doing
I think is really missed I think that
ability that skill is much more
important than again than memorizing
what happened in World War two in a
specific battle right I think if you can
teach kids to be able to be
self-confident to stand up to bullies to
believe themselves whether that's
through its own course or whether that's
through a matching a leadership training
course for students coming through one
of the things I'm looking at for my son
who's nine years old is allowing him to
be on snapchat in a public account
because he's gonna get people who love
him and he's gonna get haters and be
able to work with him on the haters I
think if you learn at nine years old how
to deal with haters someone who says
your snap sucks or your Instagram post
sucks to be able to deal with that
they'll have the self-confidence to work
through negativity at age nine I think
it's one of the greatest gifts that you
can give people and I think it's a topic
that's just completely ignored in the
education system right now
[Music]
thing number four is self-awareness I
think people just don't have
self-awareness is why I wrote your one
word it's understanding what your most
important core value is and then be able
to design a life and for the people want
to be entrepreneurs a business around it
afterwards whether you use your one word
as a template or you're using some other
model having self-awareness to
understand as a human being
what are you staying for what are your
most important core values and then how
do you design a life in a in a class you
know material perspective around that I
think too often we are trying to live up
to the expectations of our teachers of
our parents of our classmates we see
what they're doing we see how they judge
us and we just try to live up to that
instead of actually saying hey here's
what I stand for it might be different
than what my parents stand for it might
be different than what my teachers stand
for it might be different than what my
classmates same for and that's okay if
you could teach self-awareness and
giving people access to tools like your
one word or anything else you may hit
your one word awesome give them other
tools for self-awareness give them the
personality test give them any other
book that discusses a topic you can go
to Barnes and Nobles or Amazon there's a
ton of resources on this you can bring
guest speakers in exposing students to
ask questions to figure out who they are
as a human being doing that in high
school or doing that University I think
is so important because people are
making really life-changing decisions
when you decide that you're gonna go
into a university course and when you're
graduating you decide to start a
business or go into a career path a lot
of times it becomes really hard to jump
off that you're making decisions I think
it was like you're getting married
really early in life you're getting
married before you even know what dating
looks like you don't know who you are
yourself before you jump in and people
stick on a career path and have really
hard time jumping off they feel like
they've been handcuffed now because they
have debt and they have a house and they
have family and have all these things
that are binding them and it just made
the wrong decision from the get because
they had no self-awareness and so where
do people learn it they learn it from
people on YouTube they learn it by going
out to the library and researching
themselves they learn it by going online
they're not learning it in the school
system and so having an ability to teach
self awareness I think is probably one
of the most important things that you
can have
[Music]
thing number five is how to model
success and this ties into the first one
about memorizing versus learning I think
one of the most important things that
you can learn is understanding how can I
dissect what has worked for other people
to help it work for me instead of just
memorizing something from the textbook
to say here's a problem here's a problem
that I'm trying to solve who has gone
out and solved this who has done it in a
way that is meaningful and interesting
and exciting that I can learn from and
work it for me this is what saved my
business when I was in university and I
almost quit on my company I said hey I'm
not the first guy to try to solve this
thing before
who else has built a software company
that I can learn from and I learned from
Bill Gates I look at how he started how
he made his first million he said I want
to do that and it was through
partnerships and so I applied that to my
business and started actually getting
growth started as she making money
eventually building my company to be
able to sell it all from that path of
modeling success and that was a concept
that was never taught to me in school
and so if we can give students a problem
set and say go solve this we're not
gonna tell you what books to read we're
not gonna tell you what videos to watch
we're not gonna tell you who to
interview go find somebody who has
solved this already learn from them and
solve it yourself instead of giving
people the answers all the time instead
of just trying to drill in teaching
having them be creative to go out and
ask who has solved this and applied to
this problem I think is an incredibly
valuable skill it's one of the things
that I still use to this date it's one
of the most important lessons I ever
learned in my life and I wish it was
taught earlier it's something that I try
to teach to the the kids who come on my
youtube channel it's something that I
try to pass down through Hayden and the
kids that I interact with and I really
wish the school system taught it to
[Music]
thing number six has had a plan I think
in general students are not great at
planning I think people just aren't
great at planning and they need to learn
the skills and how to do it everybody
should have the option to design their
own course one of the things that was a
great for me in university I didn't even
know this was an option I found one of
my professors somebody told me about
this and my my last year I think
University where you can design your own
course if you get a professor to back
you you guys can work together and
design your own course for a credit and
so I got to design my own custom course
around pricing I applied it to the
business I was already running and
everything that I was learning
researching doing was guided by the
teacher and I was also applied to a real
practical situation in my business which
was how do i price this product that I'm
trying to sell and so even that concept
of I want to learn something I want to
design a course around that going
through that structure instead of just
feeding it to somebody say here here's
the only way to do it eat from this ball
there's no other way to do it to give
students the option to figure out what
their own course might look like and to
give them sponsorship and ownership over
that instead of just feeding it to them
I think is a great skill set to learn I
think a lot of times people struggle
going from high school to university
because everything has just been handed
to them in high school and then they go
to university and and it's a whole new
world you know a lot of times they're
away from their parents they have
complete freedom whether they come to
class or not there's nobody policing
them anymore and that that jump can be
really difficult for a lot of people
because we haven't taught them how to be
adults in high school we haven't taught
them how to plan and so I would love to
see in every year having one course
where you get to pick what you do where
you get mentored even have alumni come
in like it doesn't have to be teacher
run if teachers don't have the budget or
resources to do it
have it be fuelled by alumni I want to
be an entrepreneur so I'm gonna design
an entrepreneur course and we're gonna
find somebody in our alumni network to
grade you to mentor you to sponsor you
to give you guidance around this because
we don't have the infrastructure or the
or this knowledge set in here to be able
to help you I think that's so valuable
to give them the practical real-world
experience and teach them how to plan
[Music]
and thing number seven that they shoulda
taught you in school but didn't is how
to be an entrepreneur so many people
just want to be an entrepreneur I think
if you look at what students want to be
right now number one I think is youtuber
on there and in one to ten a ton of
those are going to be entrepreneurs just
various career options and yet we don't
teach them we don't prep them we don't
get them give them instruction we don't
train them to help get them to the path
that they want to become I think it ties
into my early point of what the success
looked like for them if they think they
want to be an entrepreneur I think
everybody should try to be an
entrepreneur just to know just to know
if it's for you or not I think if you
have on trial thoughts in your head I
think the worst thing you can do is jump
on the corporate path and stay there for
those two your life always wondering
what if and so entrepreneurship is
difficult to teach in a classroom but
what you can do is through programs like
Junior Achievement I did you know
achievement for three out of my four
high school years when you basically set
up a company in after-school hours and
you sell pens or you sell towel bindings
so you sell something that you make and
you're responsible for making it then
your sponsor from marketing it you
sponsor for selling it you're something
for counting all the things that you
need to do to run a business and
everybody has their role I would love to
see it as a class why does it have to be
an extracurricular activity afterwards
why can't entrepreneurship be a class I
think everybody should get access to
entrepreneurial experience just to see
if it's for them just like science you
know I hated science
I dropped it as soon as possible
whatever that was great 9 a great 10
when I could drop out of science and not
do it again just like we give exposure
to music I had to play you know trumpet
for a good number of years and I dropped
that pretty quickly once I got the high
school let people have an option like
the chances of somebody becoming a
musician compared to being an
entrepreneur this is a lot more people
who are going to be an entrepreneur and
we're not teaching them anything not the
NACA musicians I think music is really
important too I would give more
electives earlier on I would love to
have had the option from grade eight to
be an entrepreneur or at least get an
introduction to it and see if that might
be a path for me and so I think given
how important entrepreneurs are and I
think given how much experience that you
can get early on I think giving people
an opportunity to make a lemonade stand
at the school and keep track of their
budgets and how much they
been and marketing and selling and the
skills that go alongside it and again
getting mentors from outside alumni
people in the community to give
mentorship and help and give guidance I
think it can just make a really big
difference for people to know if they
should be an entrepreneur or not and I
think that's one of the biggest areas
that our school system currently lets us
down so those are the seven things I
think they should have taught in school
but didn't I'm gonna add one more thing
if you're a parent and you're concerned
about this at the end of the day you
still get the chance to train your kid
right you still are responsible for
educating your child much more than the
school system is and so don't deflect
the opportunity one of the greatest
things that my parents gave me the
greatest gifts is the shield they gave
me a shield against my teachers there
was one time I remember where my teacher
asked me to draw a sunset and I drew a
sunset but it was within a window and
the window was in a bedroom and the
bedroom had curtains and windows you
know shades and all this stuff and I
drew this entire room and she failed me
because she said I want you to draw a
sunset and I drew this room that then
there was a sunset in the background and
my parents came in and spoke with the
teacher and said listen you asked me to
do a sunset there's a sunset there
you didn't say you couldn't do all these
other things and so a lot of times that
could have just stifled my creativity I
could have stomped me down that could
have held me at the bottom and even
though I failed on that course on that
assignment I still felt great about
myself because my parents taught me to
believe right and so for any parents out
there I think it's your responsibility
to be the shield to be the air cover to
give protection for your kids around the
values that you think are most important
all of these seven things great they
don't teach them in school but you could
teach them yourself you still have a lot
more responsibility than your then the
teachers do and you're at your kids
school and so I encourage you to go off
and do it as well whatever it is it's
your responsibility let make it better
so those are my seven things I'd love to
know which one do you resonate with the
most is there an 8 9 10 that I'm missing
leaving the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
what what signals one was volume you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details